[Música]
el cbit solo ha puesto de relieve en las
laderas de cobertura que existen en
florida
las restricciones son muy ligeras aquí
en miami
mucha gente se murió pero eso hace parte
del virus no es algo que pueda evitarse
bienvenidos a este nuevo capítulo de
postales de campaña la cobertura
especial que france24 realiza de las
elecciones presidenciales en eeuu
nuestro viaje de más de 10 mil
kilómetros por los seis estados
decisivos en estos comicios nos trae
hasta aquí hasta florida con 29 votos
electorales este es el premio más
codiciado por ambos candidatos nadie
gana unas elecciones presidenciales en
este país sin conquistar el estado del
sol su población es diversa e
impredecible como lo son sus ajustados
resultados electorales pero vamos a
conocer un poco más a fondo esta zona
del sur del país que sabemos de florida
conocido como el estado del sol o el
estado soleado florida hace honor a su
nombre el estado limita con el golfo de
méjico y disfruta de un clima
semitropical
sitios emblemáticos de florida manglares
y pantanos incluidos los everglades un
sitio declarado como patrimonio mundial
por la unesco es el tercer estado más
poblado del país con 21 48 millones de
habitantes la mayoría concentrados en
las costas capital del estado es
tallahassee en el norte florida tiene el
mayor número de jubilados en eeuu en
relación con su población 20 9% también
hay fuertes comunidades latinas y
cubanas el turismo es la principal
fuente de ingreso del estado las playas
y los parques temáticos aportan miles de
millones de dólares al producto interno
bruto de florida cada año con 29 votos
del colegio electoral florida es un
estado crucial mientras que los
jubilados votan tradicionalmente por los
republicanos la población latina apoya a
los demócratas por lo que los resultados
siguen siendo ajustados en florida en
2016 el estado votó con un 48 6% por
donald trump
[Música]
si hay una cuestión que realmente
impactado en estas elecciones
presidenciales es la insólita crisis
sanitaria que asola el mundo eeuu
continúa recogiendo las peores cifras de
esta pandemia y no debemos olvidar que
aquí hay 30 millones de personas que no
tienen seguro médico el 37 por ciento de
ellos son hispanos precisamente una de
las minorías más golpeadas por el cob y
19 con la falta de empleo muchos han
perdido su cobertura sanitaria motivo
más que suficiente para que en estas
elecciones los latinos batán récord de
participación en las urnas yo creo que
los latinos y todo lo que pueden van a
salir y van a van a votar lo van a
mandar porque no quieren hacer un cambio
tenemos que estar bien seguro pensarlo
bien por quién vamos a votar cuando los
dos presidentes que nos da la seguridad
a nosotros para
bien bien bien
yo diría seguro yo soy socialista
entonces para mí el seguro es algo que
tiene que debe ser universal que todo el
mundo tiene derecho desde seguro médico
lo la gente pobre la gente rica el
estado de florida apostó desde el
principio por una rápida reapertura
económica y las consecuencias han sido
terribles en las últimas semanas se han
disparado los casos de contagio y
fallecimientos por kobe 19 una situación
bastante preocupante si tenemos en
cuenta que el estado del sol es el
destino favorito para las personas
jubiladas en este país
precisamente la población más vulnerable
en medio de la pandemia
richard cloud tiene 84 años y su salud
es frágil es una persona mayor que hace
parte de la población con riesgo de
sufrir complicaciones por kobe 19
las cifras en florida son totalmente
inaceptables y ridículas
muchos republicanos como yo que están
hartos del señor ton
por primera vez en sus vidas richard y
su esposa no votaron en 2016 sin embargo
son republicanos convencidos este año
apoyan al partido demócrata porque están
preocupados por el manejo de coronavirus
florida es el tercer estado más afectado
por los contagios
si nos enfermamos en nuestra edad cuando
ambos tenemos problemas de salud
nuestras posibilidades de sobrevivir son
bajas si ponemos en peligro a nuestras
familias a nuestros hijos si deciden
ayudarnos en la pandemia del cob y 19a
puesto el tema del acceso a la atención
médica en el centro de la campaña
presidencial
estos activistas intentan concienciar a
los votantes de las deficiencias del
sistema de salud y esta es la misión de
barberà considera que la salud es un
tema importante muy importante qué opina
de lo que está pasando en la corte
suprema y con la administración trump
que trata de destruir el proyecto de ley
de salud de obama
es una locura al hacerlo estarían
privando a más de 30 millones de
estadounidenses de atención médica
[Música]
en eeuu la seguridad social no es
universal el sistema se basa en un
conjunto de seguros privados muy
costosos en 2010 barack obama introdujo
una ley que requería que los
estadounidenses tuvieran un nivel mínimo
de cobertura de salud desde entonces la
administración trump ha eliminado la
obligación de asegurarse y el estado de
florida quiere revocar la ley
con el obamacare la gente tenía acceso a
la atención preventiva no terminaban en
urgencias ni quedaban con secuelas
físicas permanentes los republicanos
cambiaron la ley de salud de obama y
ahora la gente no puede pagar software
wolford una situación que se agrava con
la pandemia de kobe el 19 desde marzo
las cifras de desempleo en eeuu se han
disparado al perder sus trabajos los
estadounidenses a menudo han perdido su
cobertura médica y más de 30 millones de
personas viven hoy en día sin seguro
médico este centro en el oeste de
orlando proporciona atención gratuita a
los más necesitados pero por la pandemia
las consultas deben hacerse en línea
hoy estamos viviendo una nueva ola de
pacientes personas que hace un año
tenían muy buenos trabajos muy estables
y ahora están desempleados
un estudio wire find healthcare sauber
scanner el cob it sólo ha puesto de
relieve las lagunas de cobertura que
existen en florida fuera en promedio un
día de atención en un hospital
estadounidense cuesta cuatro mil dólares
cinco veces más que en francia para javi
la atención médica gratuita debe ser
extendida a todo el país
eeuu destina el 17 por ciento de su pib
a su sistema de salud eso es más que
cualquier otro país desarrollado sin
embargo entre 20 mil y 45 mil personas
mueren cada año por falta de atención
médica
y para conocer el impacto que la
pandemia ha tenido en los
estadounidenses nos acompaña el doctor
torres viera hoy está aquí con nosotros
venezolano experto en enfermedades
infecciosas y que además ha vivido la
enfermedad muy de cerca primero porque
usted mismo se contagió en el mes de
abril y segundo porque ha tratado
directamente con los pacientes doctor mi
primera pregunta es qué ha ocurrido en
florida para que haya habido este
aumento de casos en las últimas semanas
superando incluso a nueva york el
epicentro inicial de esta pandemia pero
yo creo que el problema de florida no lo
puede separar del problema de todos los
eeuu el problema en los estado unido en
general es que ha habido una
descoordinación en general en el en el
manejo de la pandemia y estamos
funcionando como si fuéramos los 50
estados cada uno por su cuenta sin una
coordinación a nivel federal entonces sí
se ha hecho muy difícil manejar la
pandemia ese es uno de los elementos el
siguiente elemento es que la gente se
relaja rápidamente y deja de tomar las
medidas necesarias y eso en parte tiene
que ver un poco con la politización que
ha tenido
pandemia en los eeuu entonces la gente
deja de usar la máscara se reúne
nosotros en el sur de la florida somos
muy latinos entonces tendemos a
reunirnos a dar los abrazos a estar con
la familia y esto ha sido difícil para
la gente manejarlo entonces por eso los
números en la florida se están
aumentando
creo que la rápida reapertura del
comercio de los restaurantes y demás
negocios ha facilitado también este
aumento de casa obviamente sí sin duda
de hecho lo vimos entre la primera parte
de la epidemia y la segunda que tuvimos
y ahora estamos entrando una tercera
fase vimos que una vez que logramos
controlar todo cuando se hizo una
cuarentena muy estricta
se abrió muy prematuramente a diferencia
de lo que hizo new york' por ejemplo o
lo que hizo europa y entonces cuando
empezamos a abrir la ciudad que estamos
todavía con unos niveles de transmisión
en la ciudad que era más alto de
cualquiera de estos hitos que te
mencioné y entonces tuvimos un segundo
pico de la epidemia que era incluso más
alto que el primero y ahora estamos
entrando en la tercera fase donde
también hemos abierto la ciudad
prematuramente en mi opinión y estamos
empezando a ver el aumento de los casos
en florida
a partir de una fase un poco más alta de
la que estábamos anteriormente grupos
minoritarios afroamericanos y latinos
han sido los más castigados por esta
pandemia cree que si el sistema
sanitario hubiese sido diferente se
podría haber evitado esto probablemente
si hay varias cosas que nuevamente que
tienen tienen involucra en ese punto uno
es que las minorías en los eeuu los
latinos los afroamericanos tienen a
vivir más conglomerados tienden a poseer
trabajos que son inevitables que tengas
que asistir al trabajo y entonces es más
probable en la exposición esos grupos
minoritarios el otro punto obviamente
que usted habla es el caso de las del
sistema de salud del sistema de salud de
los eeuu a pesar de ser un sistema muy
potente en términos de economía en
términos de ingresos en términos de
tecnología un sistema también bastante
disfuncional por lo es fragmentado que
está el sistema con un sistema privado
sistemas públicos con distintos
prestadores de salud de distintos grupos
privados que nos interrelacionan y eso
sube tratando de coordinar con un
sistema de salud nacional o estatal
también mucho más complicado todas esas
cosas han contribuido para qué
minorías hayan sido más representadas en
este caso que la población blanca la
vacuna también ha sido un tema muy
político cuando cree usted que estará
lista esa vacuna para hacer frente al
cobre y 19 yo creo que vamos a tener
información sobre la vacuna
probablemente para finales de este año
probablemente en noviembre o en
diciembre pero la vacuna no va a estar
lista creo que no va a hacer empezar a
ser aplicada hasta principios quizás el
primer cuarto los primeros cuatro meses
del año que viene entonces todavía nos
queda un trecho por andar en términos de
información si es posible que tengamos
información decía efectiva o no no sé
cuántas vacunas vamos a tener para el
final pero no creo que de efectivo de
aplicarse no hacer hasta del año que
viene
muchas gracias para estar con nosotros
hay un placer muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]
estas elecciones se han convertido en un
referéndum de la gestión que donald tram
ha hecho de esta pandemia el presidente
estadounidense ha tratado siempre de
restar importancia al virus incluso
cuando él mismo se contagió dijo que
había sido una bendición de dios el 65
por ciento de los estadounidenses cree
que podría haberlo evitado si se hubiese
tomado más en serio el kobe 19 hasta
aquí nuestro programa de hoy nosotros
ponemos ya rumbo a arizona que será
nuestro próximo destino para hablar de
otro tema fundamental en estas
elecciones la inmigración acompáñenos en
nuestras redes sociales o en la página
web de france 24 punto com
[Música]